Cyrille Melchior, président du
Département a convié tous les principaux
et gestionnaires des collèges publics et
privés de l'île ce mardi 25 septembre
Une rencontre conviviale et détendue qui
s'est déroulée dans les jardins de la
Villa du Département
Cyrille Melchior :
si on veut lutter contre les exclusions
il faut donner les meilleures chances à
nos enfants aux enfants de La Réunion et
cela passe par un système éducatif
performant. Et si le système éducatif doit
être performant nous devons avoir des
locaux de qualité des établissements de
qualité c'est pour cela que nous avons
lancé un programme de réhabilitation des
établissements anciens, nous soutenons
l'éducation à travers plein de projets
il y va de la promotion des jeunes
réunionnais
Commentaire :
Une matinée d'échanges
et l'occasion de rappeler les grands axes
de la politique éducative menée par le
Département.
Il y a le projet de construction de reconstruction
il y a des projets de réhabilitation de rénovation
en tous les cas ce que je peux dire en
un mot c'est que le Département oeuvre avec le, comment
la volonté de notre président Cyrille
Melchior
c'est de faire en sorte qu'il y ait un
mieux-vivre pour note jeunesse réunionnaise
au milieu
en fait dans l'éducation même et nous y
apportons notre pierre, et au combien
utile pour beaucoup d'entre nous.
Commentaire :
Le Département, un partenaire indispensable.
960 emplois sont financés par la
collectivité en faveur des collèges.
Le montant total de la masse salariale
représente 44 millions d'euros,
ajoutez à cela les 41 millions d'euros
pour l'entretien, l'aménagement, la
réhabilitation et la construction des
collèges.
Le Département est un bien évidemment
un partenaire privilégié hein,
on ne pourrait pas fonctionner si nous
n'avions pas la collectivité donc
c'était intéressant aussi par exemple
ben de mettre en valeur aujourd'hui
toutes les actions, tout ce partenariat
constructif au service des élèves
C'est non seulement une bonne initiative mais
c'est nécessaire que,
vous savez l'école n'est jamais toute seule
elle travaille avec plein de partenariats
et le Département
est un partenaire important pas
seulement pour les collèges d'ailleurs
mais pour d'autres aspects de
l'éducation qui concerne le social la
santé donc des rencontres régulières et
des rencontres qui sont
positives et qu'il faut que les gens se
parlent et
c'est une très bonne chose.
Commentaire :
La matinée s'est achevée par une remise de
médailles à quatre collégiens ayant
accompli des actes d'héroïsme ou de
solidarité.